michel poniatowski bonsoir merci d'être
robin sait où ça vous change non un peu
ça vous va un très bien gérard est très
simple tricot m dos fait depuis quelques
temps vous voit un peu moins dans les
médias est ce que c'est parce que bon
vous n'avez plus de fonctions
ministérielles bien entendu mais quand
même on vous êtes mois chouchou des
médias qui à une époque
est ce que parce que vous avez fait des
gaffes parce que vous avez dit des gros
mots ou des choses comme ça les gars je
n'en sais rien des livres aux mots c ou
qui l'apprécié non c'est surtout parce
que je suis parlement européen que je
voyage beaucoup en europe et ailleurs
aux états unis en russie au japon et que
j'essaie de voir quelle est la situation
mondiale pour la nuit des musées
analyser la situation européenne car
tout ça va très très vite
on assiste aujourd'hui un 7 d'or aux
victoires de l'entreprise aux victoires
de la musique alors nous avant minuit on
a décidé de créer un pony adore alors
j'essaie venait de mes filles y en a
trois et la 3d sur nous alors on a va
demander de décerner pwner le ponia d'or
à l'homme politique de l'année à
l'écrivain de l'année et aux
journalistes de l'année alors à l'homme
politique de l'année dernière pour vous
j'aime politique de l'année
shelly des fils de m ah bon les joueurs
là non pas du tout mais vais jouer mais
je pense que willam clairac numérique
alors à l'étranger et produisant à
l'étranger ni à gauche et est allée tout
le centre ouvert à tout le monde fait
quelques erreurs l'étranger je fais vous
ne riez pas des mots comme on n'a pas
encore ce sera l'année prochaine il lui
donnera le pony à doral labardin portant
la responsabilité de l'action c'est
l'année prochaine s'il est élu que l'on
se met alors à l'étranger de médias
allait trop si il va nous dire
gorbatchev exactement
j'ai alors pourquoi alors maintenant que
ça ait changé le dixième des trucs parce
que il est entre
d'essayer de transformer un pays qui est
complètement ce rosé est complètement
bureaucratisé est complètement en dehors
du temps faut bien réaliser que je
m'entraîne pas passer dans la
civilisation scientifique qui cèdent les
dunes du siècle prochain et lui vit
encore en partie avec le 19e siècle et
lille hazard monial heures pour
permettre à ses contacts comptes n'en
possédez pas séduit limagne adore
apparaît alors à l'écrivain un écrivain
à l'écrivain de dante
il va me dire tahar bendjelloun non non
non non non non non mais ne pourra pas
le mérite et tahar ben jelloun on dit
qu'il a copié son livre non mais plus je
peux à lui se donne pour montpellier la
façon pagne adore alors leur maison
peut-être passé littéraire un livre
d'histoire peut-être non tout internet
histoire
l'anru si j'avais elle mais là je vais
tomber dans mes préférences pour ce
magazine c'est tout ce qu'on vous dit et
c'est ce serait un tube gens tuent la
wii pour les normes au dictionnaire qui
l'a fait sur le sur napoléon et toutes
les peaux laval il y en avait d'autres
écrans pierce et vos ancêtres tout ça
alors un journaliste monia d'or du
journalisme et même peut-être à tesson
pour avoir sauvé sur provisoirement son
journal fois des griffes de goldsmith
pouvez vous ne jetez pas d'eau non
négatif de jimmy goldsmith je trouve
qu'ils sont très bien battus pour pour
maintenir en vie le quotidien
alors maintenant on va faire les
antilles faire les antilles ponia d'or
alors les pony admet alors un homme
politique à qui vous le donne à riez le
pire homme politique de l'année vraiment
celui qui est le plus nul
et sur ce point
non parce que la sécession la
dissolution est mais je pense que le
plus complet sur la plage
c'est probablement la joie ni à l'amour
on vous reconnaît la wiiu mais c'est
vrai bon c'est vraiment il a le plein de
bois c'est l'absence totale l'idée c'est
la répétition des des résultats ci alors
après un journal on serait plus mauvais
journaliste bonne affaire du genre est
bon or ils vont se trouver à l'humanité
l écrivain et plus mauvais des crayonnés
mon paquet lingue non on va vous faire
réagir sur incertaine sur un certain
nombre de gens alors je vais vous donner
je vais citer une liste de noms et puis
disent aux gens vous allez donc réagir
alors si je vous dis valéry giscard
d'estaing comme répondez vous j'aime
beaucoup même beaucoup à voir mais
toujours beaucoup j'aime beaucoup et je
pense que c'est un des hommes politiques
les plus intelligents les plus lucides
que nous ayons correspond pas au profil
tu aimerais que veulent les français
mais c'est l'homme le plus remarquable
que nous ayons sur la série mais pas
varié là dessus non ça fonctionne
toujours par télépathie comme vous avez
pu le dire vous à l'écart entre giscard
et non c'était de la télé et c'était
c'est vrai mais c'est plus que ça c'est
la perche et le jugement sur l'homme
peul et aujourd'hui c'est encore plus
que ça oui on continue alors donc
raymond barre à raymond barre vraiment
basse et la sécurité il s'est
probablement ce que nous pouvons avoir
de mieux pour gérer ce que veulent les
français parce que ça serait quand même
giscard sinon
pour gérer la france à l'heure actuelle
c'est françois mitterrand c'était un
sérum au final je me trompe plus qu'ils
puissent apporter quelque chose
d'important à la france la france et
qu'il a fait là dernièrement je pense
qu'il a assuré l'unité française pendant
les deux années de cohabitation et
c'était très important quand il parlait
et léa tard il faut qu'ils se forment
cours dans sept ans peut mieux faire
dans cette envolée de le faire la faire
je pense qu'il doit se forme qui va mais
qu'il va prendre complètement son métier
c'est un très bon ministre l'intérieur
un excellent milles derrière
excellent vous êtes expert en la matière
la paix et que l'on est meilleur que
vous aimez york
oui je crois alors j'ai 15 ans j'ai 15
ans je le jure qu individu sympathique
par son indépendance mais en fait tout
ça c'est des points des projets krasucki
mauvrit errecart michel rocard les jeux
et les laits pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de finale andy tube abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus